Indium is a very soft metal. I haven’t got
a sample here. It
melts at 150 degrees or so.
This is an example of indium it is a really,
really quite nice
chemical element this one. We can use it for
lots and lots of
selective types of catalysis, but generally
when it is forming a
complex with other organic ligands. But here
we can see a
really nice example of indium and this is
99.9% pure.
But it’s a metal which has suddenly become
very much more
expensive because its oxide is transparent
to light but will
conduct electricity. So it is indium oxide
that you find on
every LCD display. Here is a rather old computer
and here is
an old fashioned computer, the LCD display
was quite small
and gradually they have got bigger and bigger
and therefore
demand for indium oxide is more and more and
probably you
are watching this video clip through a thin
layer of indium
oxide.
This sample although it’s very small, is
5 grams. So it is a
really, really, dense metal, very, very expensive
and very,
very valuable as well.
But indium is also used as solder for soldering
various metals
together and it is also quite useful if, I
used it in my youth,
when we were making low temperature apparatus
and we
wanted to screw two things together and get
a nice seal in
between them, you could screw them together
with a thin
sheet of indium, and that almost welded them
together.
So indium wire; it is very, very malleable
and very, very soft
and very easy to form into shapes. I am not
going to touch it
though because it will cause some significant
problems for
me, because it does cause toxicity if it comes
into contact
with the skin; so lovely piece of indium wire.